merci d'être avec nous habiter en
bourgogne vous êtes retraité avait 76
ans moi je dis parce que avec le maquis
en fait 15 de moins merci non mais 76 en
remercie non non non pas du tout je vois
bien qu'est ce qui vous a fait vous
tourner vers le front national
et ils rassemblement national vous avez
vous avez toujours voté front national
non quand j'étais étudiante à l'époque
c'était très élevé je travaillais en
banque et j'ai une 68 on pouvait aller
en fac le soir
donc c'est ce que j'ai fait passer une
licence de lettres et d'y enseigner mais
j'ai enseigné dans des structures
d'enfants malades
voilà c'était mon choix oil corp après
je me fais la fête c'est ma période punk
ou la politique
et bien ma foi qui pensait pas se penser
plus à faire là ce n'est pas le faire la
politique c'est une très bien vécu j'ai
fait ou stop tout ça bon vous avez bien
fait c'est bien vécu voilà j'ai évité
rang masque pourquoi pas l'essayer 88
euros 80 ou voilà 88 toute nue non pas
en 88 j'ai commencé à dévier et aux faux
airs nfr virage sur le taux de déviation
ça me correspondait mieux qu est ce qui
vous a séduit dans leur nc jean-marie le
pen dont 88 eh bien il ya eu quelques
dérapages mais il a quand même dit des
choses vraies et que ton deuil on
vendait mériel vous vous condamnez ces
dérapages
oui oui parce que je les condamne bien
et comme tout le monde parce qu'il ya
les images à l'appui il ya quand même
les documents
il ya tout ça mais on ne peut pas lui
nier et vous c'est ça on va les pieds
dans le plat vous ce qui ce qui vous a
plu dans le don dans le front national
c'est quoi ces c'est le seuil autisme
d'accord comme la france comme si la
france m'a bel françois vous avez
l'impression que c'est le seul essai le
seul parti qui défend la france que vous
votre tout à fait sympathique existe qui
déforme la france qui préserve son
patrimoine
nous sommes comme disait jean une des
racines chrétiennes
moi je suis pour toutes les régions en
france nous avons des tas de religion ce
que veut ne pas c'est qu'on ait une qui
prédomine sur l'autre et actuellement il
y en a pas ou si l'islam bolloré domine
sur la chrétienté lente alors poindre
j'aimerais pas là pour répondre là
dessus parce que maintenant ça fait mal
et voilà c'est vrai que c'est excellent
c'est la révélation
voilà c'est cela le vrai mais cela dit
qu'elle était pour toutes les religions
oui et puis ensuite moi j'ai je voulais
réagir mais je suis ça va venir
l'islam et ça et puis tout de suite
remarqué consacre un discours tout tenté
sur le séparatisme ethnique si vous
voulez qui part du 10ème c'est que c'est
un sujet laisser parler malek souplet
cheval est ce que vous avez à répondre
alors madame vous vous avez voté dont
fera front national bill début quand
vous me dites il ya quelques dérapages
et laurence l'a rappelé le les chambres
à gaz pente détail de la seconde guerre
mondiale c'est un des pires impacts
dérapages c'est que ce soit quand c'est
jallet que les écoles et qu'on dise que
c'est juif et l'autre que c'est une
petite chose parmi tant de choses je
suis désolé ça ne rien sans rêver suis
désolé mais comme comment dupond-moretti
10 oc petit sauvage jean petit et braga
de l'état
une soirée où la loi ne plaît pas tous
sens que la loi
je suis désolé mais c'est deux poids
deux mesures
on aimerait bien pouvoir réagir avec
autant de armes sur l'antisémitisme et
son ami si madame par exemple faire un
procès d'intention qui ne vous dit
comment kimi qu'est-ce qui vous dit que
je ne fais toutes mes forces je vous ai
jamais entendu je suis le seul rond de
vous l'entendre on dit aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui si vous aussi vous prendre
révélation il vous parle et on peut
penser ces jours ci pour parer
d'antisémitisme je suis d'accord avec
vous mais il faut condamner tous les
anti sémitisme c'est le principal
lang à ces miss nationale c'est pas le
vecteur qu'on verrait cela me rappelle
qu'on donne toute la haine qu'elle vous
êtes aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]